certainly didn't have a good first third
of the event but got a rest day and he's
back with a win jeffrey first take us
through the psychology of not playing
like yourself losing three in a row is
not something that you do
even once every five years
yeah it was a very tough start obviously
um
i think the most annoying part though
was
i just felt like i wasn't fighting well
um
i mean playing bad moves making mistakes
is one thing but
i just felt like any time i felt some
kind of slight pressure i would just
immediately crumble so
yeah i took the rest day was very timely
for me to
watch some football and regroup a little
bit i was wondering what the formula was
he said watching football what game did
you watch
uh well it was nice to watch uh my
cowboys dominate oh yeah
oh my goodness
my brother in arms go dallas all right
we'll forgive you for that
indiscretion
so you watch and got got motivated and
then you came into today feeling
uh
rambunctious ready to play and you
played c3 on move two talk us through
that move yeah it was a move that
actually gave me
uh personally some
trouble i mean it was just kind of
confusing i think
magnus played it against me in uh 2017
isle of man
and i also was very confused because it
can often transpose into a london for
example and
it's kind of a london where
bishop gets stuck on c8 so i was hoping
maybe sam would get confused as well and
i think he didn't really get what he
wanted out of the opening all right all
right so you got this position as we
look here
and
when he played the move f5
did you fall out of your chair or
did you think ah it's a move uh i felt
like when he played knight g6
i thought that was maybe the first step
in the wrong direction i i was expecting
f6 here
because
actually if he goes f6
i'm not sure if i can castle because
then he takes on g3 and e5 and maybe
he gets some sort of initiative
so
yeah i was a little bit worried about
this at least i needed to find another
way
but when i when he played h6 i was happy
because then i go queen c2
and actually besides f5 it's not so easy
for him to play another move honestly
um
because he needs to develop
the c8 bishop but he also doesn't want
to take on g3 and b6 is a little slow so
i mean f5 yeah it's very uh
i mean concedes quite a bit but at the
same time i wasn't sure what else to do
all right so then you started rolling
there was a moment when he looked like
he wanted you to repeat
and you offered once and then you said
psych
why'd you continue
uh yeah i at first my idea with bishop
f1 was kind of to vacate the d3 square
for me to maneuver maybe the other
knight via b3 but then i realized that
if i do that i think he goes e5
and i wasn't sure if
how good that is for me actually
so then i was happy to find this idea
kind of broke a6 so i can go sorry yeah
so you originally you wanted after
knight c6 to
go knight to b3 yeah yeah
and then you were a little bit well how
good is e5 yeah
okay
so you decided instead to repeat the
position and then come up with
a4 sorry please i'm sorry press pause
for just a second jeffrey forgive us
this time pressure happening could we go
to the fabiano caruana game the board
itself the two players sitting there
producer because i think bobby's down to
34 seconds and he did move and now he's
down to a minute he had a big decision
about what to do and he did capture he
has to make five
more moves
five more moves from this moment
and down to only 50 seconds ticking down
you see his opponent with a ton of time
on the clock yeah you said you didn't
want to see this position at all
fabi looks like he's in serious trouble
here that great bishop the rook about to
take the pawn back and fabi sitting up
in his chair down to only 34 seconds
jeffrey your thoughts about this
position
yeah i'm honestly very surprised because
when i saw this game earlier i thought
it was very pleasant for
for white so yeah this is quite a sudden
change we put ourselves on the spot we
have to predict the result uh jeffrey
white wins losers or draws
um
okay
i will go with the draw
what
what all right so bishop b2 rooksy for
bishop a3
you think you can keep that pawn on b
well yeah three contains
rook c1
what do you like that rook c5 or do you
go bishop b2 bishop takes b2 bishop to
create that past pawn yeah that's what i
was thinking i thought roxy one was a
mistake i it looks like it bishop takes
b two it's never ripped c four there
bishop takes a three c six
b b e two three
and don't i just go and pick up this
knight somehow i can't believe it how do
you do it how do i do it so let's say i
go bishop e7 put it on f6 and then bring
my king
yeah you just you'll have a pawn on b2
which will be forever protected by the
bishop i think that's winning and rook
c5 knight c3
also looks awesome i mean i'll also try
to bring my king i think quickly f34 and
then
fair yeah that seems fair
unclear to me so i think this is the
three two i think it's bishop e2 let's
just take a quick gander sorry
well actually jeffrey we'll we'll abuse
you while you're in uh our witness
protection program we won't give up your
identity how did we do this for a moment
ago
we're here
here
and something like okay we like this
move to just put our bishop
and
you can bring your king over
but
what is
this situation we'll bring our king over
and our king
and our bishop
i this i gotta believe this should be
winning so you go to d5 king to e4 king
e4 and you have to try to stop making d5
okay can i
king
c5 i guess
if king c5 doesn't seem like c7 just
king d7
finishes the game almost feels it
feels like it
and the engine's giving a win for both
moves rook c5 and bishop takes on b2 wow
both moves both win as a win yes appears
moves so rook takes c5 knight c3 what's
the winning maneuver bringing the king
in is what it wants to do
bringing the king to the queen side king
f8
i'm just saying big advantage because
you're always in this kind of stuck
but
jeffrey's response was well wait a
minute aren't i bringing my king also
into this well we can debate whether or
not the engine is right
jeffrey's right right now jeffrey's on
the hook for a draw
let's get back to his game uh
the position where we had
uh for his his game if you can pull it
up sorry where are we it's
here
no that's going to be that's the last
game
that's good all the way at the bottom
sorry
okay we left it
uh actually we left it here where you
decided to come up with the a4
b4 expansion
jeffrey yeah i quite like this idea
basically i want to
activate my rook on a1 and also
as you see in the as you saw in the game
i wanted to go c4 and activate all of my
pieces
it worked like a charm
did does it mean where did he go wrong
where did you
really feel like holy smokes this is
really great i mean already after after
i found this idea with b5 i was
extremely happy okay
very good because it really looked just
about
at this point when you had your pawns on
b5 and c5 this is when you were really
starting to
dominate i thought yeah the the issue
for him he's he needs to
find some kind of counter play but i'm
just too safe
right
okay so
after this everything kind of
went smoothly for you
yeah yeah i think knight d4 was
very strong right
the last really really good move
and suddenly well
boom
yeah over over
besides the dallas cowboy game the other
game i really wanted to ask you about
was oklahoma versus texas i thought that
was just an incredible game did you see
that 51-41
in the fourth quarter and the sooners
pulled it out 48-41 i was heartbroken go
longhorns yeah yeah my sister my sister
goes to you i mean she she graduated
from ut so yeah it was very painful very
painful very painful congratulations
jeffrey welcome back to the tournament
good to see you
hope you show up on the show soon uh
as well me too
all right